je vous propose maintenant chère madame
meunier de vous présenter monsieur jean
carmet je le présente aussi au aux
candidats bien sûr mais c'est d'abord à
la dame que je présente ce jeune premier
éternelle c'est cet art le cas c'est par
le coeur joyeux au lit par l'amour
possible par ce tourangeau exporté à
paris qui est mon ami jean carmet gens
d'ailleurs je suis très embarrassée
parce que tu sais que la tradition et de
la tradition est ce que vous voyez mais
enfin quand on se connaît depuis si
longtemps et on se pose toujours la
question chaque fois qu'on se rencontre
devant les microphones
alors écoutons va le terme et on va dire
un coup tu inconnu voilà tu me direz
vous nous faisons ça l'amitié les usages
seront respectés je vais essayer de te
tutoyer essaye de me voilà de toute
façon on voit des affiches partout en
france en ce moment où il ya jean carmet
qui est affiché comme avec un titre à la
audiard et 3 qui est censuré d'ailleurs
enfin qu'ils sont sûrs quand on essaie
deux points et quand on laisse j'ai peur
d'y charger une petite hypocrisie là
dedans je ne sais pas qui ça choque
j'ai d'être tellement traité j'ai
tellement je gagne ma vie m'enjoint
l'essai
oui c'est un mot pour lequel je n'ai pas
la gratitude pauvres c'est de l'être
alors voilà il s'agit vous voulez le
dire de ce film comment réussir quand on
essaie et pleurnichard et en effet je
dois dire c'est qu'il ya deux points de
suspension mais tout je crois que le
spectateur aura corrigé de lui même je
ne sais pas et je ne sais pas le mou est
quand même assez utilisé il ya un moment
la paix est respectueuse à l'uemoa
autres vous encore la question
la perdrix respecteuse la partie s'il
est bien là c'est peut-être quand on est
carmet pleurniche 1 voilà non parce
qu'il ya deux noms ça peut s'identifier
d'ailleurs parce que j'utilisais dirais
que c'est un point première j'ai souvent
gagner ma vie en jouant des personnages
qui fait que quand on dit qu'ils sont
c'est oui mais alors celui là se révèle
être un malin en fait un malin c'est une
idée très de kassak que michel audiard
oui oui oui il a fait un contrepoids
j'ai l'impression que les comédiens ont
apporté leur sève à dire des mots et des
expressions de mon ami car mais que je
retrouve là où c'est possible parce
qu'avec audiard on travaille en famille
un peu entre deux promenades à vélo
entre deux promenades à vélo mais il
était servi là dedans par des comédiens
que j'aime beaucoup qui sont grands amis
et que lui rencontré sur un plateau pour
la première fois il s'agit de stéphane
audran d'evelyne bill et puis de jane
birkin
les trois dames que chez lui par mes
larmes dans le flou
et puis comme come home autour de ces
dames et il y avait jean rochefort et
marielle et ce sont des êtres que je
ridiculisait moi par mes larmes mais par
mon charme n'entraînant leurs dames dans
dans ma couche je croyais enfin peut pas
raconter fils mais on peut quand même si
tu es ton personnage en disant que tu es
un représentant en apéritif s'appelle le
vu le cas ni le volcanique et à
l'apéritif tellement tellement répugnant
que personne n'en veut alors il donne un
prix bhl se représente en sauveur paix
il donne en prime une une superbe
pendule killy qui joue au sol et mios
qui s'allume et qui salue mother il
donne sa en prime et même même avec
cette cette prime superbe ils n'arrivent
pas à vendre
alors il a un truc il se raconte à
lui-même des histoires qu'ils racontent
après aux autres raconte
et puis se met à pleurer en les
racontant dit qu'il est orphelin et
c'est pas très joli comme personnage
mais malgré tout il aime beaucoup sa
mère 1
il raconte des histoires qui l'histoire
de sa malheureuse en france mais avec la
complicité de sa mère il a un don il a
un bon physique extraordinaire c'est que
dès qu'il raconte ses histoires l'ied
cesser ses malheurs conjugaux avec une
dame qui s'appelle aidelise parce que
tout ça est fait dans un langage
précieux et bien quand il raconte ses
malheurs conjugaux par exemple il se
fixe et ses yeux s'embuent il ya de très
grosses larmes alors à ce moment là on
ne peut plus le châssis on lui passe une
commande alors ils accèdent à des une
position supérieure devient directeur
d'un grand hôtel parisien mais à la
suite de ça il se rend compte qu'il
n'est pas tellement fait pour ça et il
chute et alors à l'aide de ses propres
malheurs elle cette fois c'est il va
pouvoir recommencer non pas à placer les
apéritifs mais a placé ses pendules ce
que j'admire j'en suis je ne cherche pas
du tout à me convaincre moi tu cherche à
convaincre les général l'invité me
regarde jamais
tu vas tu dois encore bon et bien donc
le film d'audiard est impoli avec les
téléspectateurs parce que je me disais
quoi regarder salut salut ces messieurs
dames
et bien quand on essaie et pleurnicharde
michel audiard avec jean carmet une
superbe équipe de comédiens est
actuellement tu tournes encore un autre
film avec audiard avec michel audiard
c'est d'après un roman s'appelle le
principe d'archimède et le film va
s'intituler bons baisers à lundi
c'est une histoire dont c'est pas une
histoire de céder mal de temps encore
ce sont des gens qui veulent aller enfin
faux pas je ne raconte pas ce qu'il y'a
un suspense dans ce film we avait commis
sa camarade ajouté l'enfant oui non ce
sont des gens qui se trompent des tâches
ils vont faire un hold up mais sont plus
forts de la reprise individuelle ils
vont chez les riches d'une sorte de
prendre abominable et là ils vont faire
de la reprise individuelle ils se
trompent d'étagés sont passés à un
chèque sans provision un samedi soir ils
sont obligés de rester quand même
jusqu'au lundi avec les gens ils
deviennent très ami avec les gens alors
là il ya encore une belle équipe dans la
lah bernard blier qui joue le sale type
petit à siéger parmi les assiégeants est
un jeune acteur qui s'appelle moreau et
un autre qui s'appelle consolier parmi
les assiégés il ya evelyne bull est venu
déjà nommé il ya maria pacôme il ya
mario david et son beau torse et jean
carmet et jean-louis bien sûr et puis
alors y ait encore d'autres projets
démocrates bernard blier que site pour
la deuxième fois comme il l'a fait et
bien sûr je crois qu'il y à une suite au
grand blond les noyaux succès avait dit
vendeur je vais retrouver tout le monde
s'y retrouve et au sport je retrouvais
différentes personnes riches à un
richard mireille darc mais je ne
retrouverai pas oubliée parce que blier
été tués dans la première version il me
dire qu'il fait une drôle
mais ce sont des choses qui arrivent
belmondo a été tué dans le premier
borsalino et bien cher jean voici de
savoureux projet une actualité brûlante
on dit généralement qu'elle est brûlante
louis vitry dans les milieux
généralement bien informé jusqu'alors
michael l'allée chaude en tout cas et je
vous propose madame et messieurs de
trouver le titre d'un film